cloud migration
is top of mind for many organizations
today
while moving to the cloud can be full of
challenges the cloud offers many
advantages around
increased agility new and innovative
services
and on-demand pricing that traditional
data centers don't offer
so let's talk about one way to make
migration easier
hosting your applications in a native
vmware environment
right in google cloud google cloud
vmware engine
is built to address the biggest issues
that prevent most workloads from moving
to the cloud
lack of resources and the cost of
re-architecting apps
with google cloud vmware engine you can
migrate your apps with no
changes to your processes because you
run your applications
on native vmware vms in a dedicated and
private sddc
this means you can use the same tools
processes
and policies while still getting the
advantages of being in the cloud
all on top of deeper integration with
other google cloud services
and it doesn't take long to spin up an
environment you can quickly lower your
total cost of ownership
and spend more time planning how to
re-architect down the road
let's walk through a demo of how to set
up google cloud vmware environment with
just a few clicks
after clicking the navigation menu we'll
scroll down to the compute section
and click vmware engine which takes us
to an overview page
the overview provides you with
additional details about the service
and allows you to perform common
operations like launching the vsphere
client
creating a private cloud and adding and
managing users
we'll create a private cloud by clicking
the create private cloud button
then entering a name for our new cloud
we'll stick with usc for the location
and keep the node count at the minimum
number of three we'll input the cider
range for our management appliances
then click review and create while our
private cloud is being created
let's talk about pricing which is per
node and includes all the storage
compute and licensing to run your vmware
environment
you'll pay monthly by default but you
can also sign up for one
or three year plans to reduce costs
after our private cloud is created
we can access it from the resources
screen which is where you can view
and manage all your private clouds we'll
click our new private cloud to view the
configuration details
this is where you can view a summary of
your cloud details including which
versions of vsphere
nsxt and hcx you're currently using
the links in the upper right of the
screen allow you to launch the virtual
center client
which is the standard enterprise virtual
center client vmware users know today
and expand your cloud by adding nodes
there are also additional options at the
bottom of the screen
that let you remove nodes delete your
cloud and
elevate your vsphere privileges an
important feature that gives you admin
access and vcenter
so you can make the configuration
changes necessary to run certain
third-party software
let's scroll back up to the top of the
screen and launch our vsphere client
after logging in you can see that we're
working with the same
vsphere interface that's so familiar to
admins this native access to vmware
provides you a standard way to control
your applications
while still getting all the benefits of
running on google cloud now let's return
to the management console page
and take a look at the networking
details and configuration options
this is where you can view your firewall
tables and your subnets
create a public ip with just a single
click
setup and manage vpn gateways configure
and manage your dns profiles
and create and manage private
connections to google services
the activities interface provides
important details for your security and
operations teams
including environment alerts details
about past events
and any currently running tasks and
their status
your team can also audit logs of any
activities performed by users
the account screen provides a summary of
your entire vmware engine environment
including all your private clouds and
lets you subscribe to email alerts
and ad distribution lists the account
screen is also where you can manage any
users that have access to the
environment
one really nice feature of the vmware
engine is the native integration into
google services
all the billing related to the service
is integrated seamlessly into the online
account management system
which allows you to see all the usage of
your vmware engine dedicated nodes
right in line with your other google
cloud services with this quick tour
we've shown you how to quickly generate
a private
native vmware environment on google
cloud and use all the same tools and
processes you're already familiar with
the environment is fully supported by
vmware and gives you the ability to
create hybrid apps that integrate
seamlessly with google cloud services
google cloud vmware engine is available
for you to try out now
so check out the documentation to learn
more details and spin up your own
private vmware environment